Why Don't Water and Oil Mix?
olive-oil-in-waterMade of different elements,
and with distinct structures, densities and
even dissimilar polarities, it’s no wonder
oil and water don’t get along.
They can be forced to cooperate, however,
and there are several examples of this that
are likely currently sitting in your pantry
or refrigerator.
But why don’t oil and water normally mix?
Water (H20) is a stubby molecule with a slightly
positive charge on the hydrogen (H) end, and
a slightly negative charge on the oxygen (O)
end (the oxygen atom actually “steals”
electrons from the hydrogen atoms).
Called a polar molecule, the negative poles
on each water molecule are attracted to the
positive poles on other water molecules, and
as a result, they knit tightly together with
hydrogen bonds.
In fact, oil floats on water because it is
less dense, with these super-tight hydrogen
bonds between water molecules holding them
closer together than the bonds between the
fatty-acid molecules that primarily make up
oil.
As for oil, it is a non-polar chemical.
Since the atoms in the fatty acids in oil
share their electrons nicely, they (usually)
have no charge, or at least not enough to
make the whole molecule polar.
Given their lack of positive or negative charge,
they are not attracted to a polar molecule
like water.
Given that oil essentially “repels” the
water, it is called hydrophobic or “water
fearing,” as opposed to hydrophilic or “water
loving.”
As such, eventually all the lipophilic or
“fat loving” oil molecules will join together
floating on top of the water.
However, although they seem determined to
stay apart, it is possible to mix oil and
water in a more or less stable solution, and
there are several examples of this in your
kitchen.
One of the more common examples where this
occurs is in salad dressing.
To get the two main ingredients, vinegar (essentially
water with acetic acid) and oil, to combine
and stay that way for some amount of time
involves two steps: breaking the oil into
tiny droplets so it can be evenly dispersed
throughout the mixture, and adding a mediator,
called an emulsifier.
The end solution is then known as emulsion.
Different emulsifiers work in different ways.
Some, like lecithin (found in egg yolks),
have both a hydrophobic end (that oil likes)
and a hydrophilic end (that water likes);
thus capable of bonding with both oil and
water.
So, as long as the oil droplets are sufficiently
tiny and thoroughly dispersed (and enough
emulsifier is used) the combination of oil
and vinegar will remain as a relatively stable
blend or emulsion.
On the other hand, an emulsifier like tomato
paste has protein molecules that more or less
coat the oil droplets and prevent them from
bonding together, keeping them relatively
well dispersed in the water.
While it gets there differently, when well
mixed, the end result is about the same.
So, when making a typical dressing, you first
mix together the emulsifier (or emulsifiers)
and the vinegar, and then slowly add a thin
stream of oil while whisking or blending vigorously
and constantly.
Between the thin stream and determined whisking,
the oil will be broken into tiny drops and
dispersed; and, since the emulsifier is there
to either coat the oil or bind it to the vinegar,
it will remain suspended in the mixture for
a good deal
of time.